[Music]
kisses and hugs gosh I love y'all
Nicki Minaj can't contain herself after
locking lips with Madonna backstage at
Monday's MTV Video Music Awards the 35
year old rapper was thanked with the
kiss after she took to social media to
wish the Queen of Pop he turned 60 on
August 16th a happy bday this isn't the
very first time Nicki has been touched
by the Material Girl singer she laid a
wet one on the rapper at her 30th
birthday party and Madonna isn't a
stranger to kissing at the VMAs in 2003
she famously shared an on-stage smooch
with Britney Spears during their racy
rendition of like a virgin
[Music]
but back to 2018 the night wasn't all
fun for Madge she got in some hot water
after paying tribute to the late Queen
of Soul Aretha Franklin you're probably
all wondering why I'm telling you this
story there's a connection because none
of this would have happened could have
happened without our Lady of soul
viewers found Madonna's speech
self-indulgence
slamming her online for making it about
her own life and career instead of a
Rita's legacy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]